my one reservation with this video is
that it's going to turn a lot of you
into just spam bots that you're just
going to control copy go into DM and
start pasting and getting banned or
paused by Instagram because you're just
spamming you're just spamming you can
see in the beginning of the video in
this first couple minutes when I said
see how you can bring them value your
entire entire energy is predicated on
what can I get out of this I'm going to
DM the rock I'm going to DM Warren
Buffett I'm going to DM Tyra Banks I'm
going to be M this founder and you're
not thinking about what does that person
actually need right now the key to any
tactic and this is a tactic the key to
any tactic is to provide more value to
the other person especially when they're
the one with leverage hustling 24/7 on
the Instagram DM it is the 2017
opportunity
[Music]
I see a lot of people watching this have
no idea what Instagram really is and why
it's special tell me it's a very simple
photo app here's something interesting
any application that makes your life
better is a big Instagram it will be
easily one of the top two social
networks in America and globally will be
a major force it's a beast it is the
current social network of the moment and
I just think it's an incredibly
important platform I'm very very bullish
on and somebody who day trades attention
I think it's a massive Instagram is very
very important I think that you should
probably starting now for a month from
now launch I would Matt I would be
searching hashtags and I would start
building relationships right now I truly
think the attention on Instagram from
individuals is unbelievable Tehran has
hundreds of millions of people but
here's one way I promise you that you
will not build your Instagram profile by
not doing anything by sitting and having
a beer with your friend and complaining
that it's so hard to build your profile
search hashtags click them look at the
account then see how you can bring them
value DM them going soft bring value
rinse and repeat two three four five
thousand times I'm going to give you a
piece of advice that is 100 percent and
the only reason you won't be successful
is because you're not hungry enough and
you're too lazy you ready yes good I
want you to go to Instagram are you
watching me on Instagram yes I want you
to stop watching learning chagrin I want
you to start this process if you're
hungry if you want to win you have to do
for five to seven hours a day
you ready yes I want you to search a
hashtag I want you to go to the search
up top I want you to search grocery for
local butcher plumber when you search it
for me a hashtag and then I wanted to
spend 25 minutes Hey
every picture that has a hashtag plumber
and see if it's the account of a
plumbing company or a plumber who has a
small business and you see who this is
so this is a custom design firm its b2b
commercial in Toronto under 48 thousand
followers this or that they post I want
you then click the URL that is linked to
that person's account and look at their
website if they have a good website
leave him alone
if the website is [ __ ] I want you to go
back into Instagram and hit the top
right corner triple button people right
here profile
hit send a message to get us directly
for this message and then here is the
key and send them a message and say yo
this is me I'm the best
a small biggest website design your
website is not on point I've got a thing
that's 500 bucks up front 25 bucks a
month and you will crush it and you'll
return on that investment in one day let
alone one year because your website will
be stronger that you're linked to on
Instagram and you'll convert better and
I want you to do that for 5 to 7 hours
every single day which means that your
message between 70 and 250 people a day
and you'll do a lot of business is this
development it's one of the pillars of
my success so be kind of good at
business development is I try to bring
more value to the other person first I
think about it like sawdust if you've
got downtime
why not business develop the fact you
can business develops and this thing now
is insane and if you offer something in
return
three other 30 people will take you up
on it you may not but the next person
might and then you business develop in
business event and things start
happening let's show another one Xerox
the Fitness hashtag you know only 168
million
break7 the top post and most recent so
you go to a top purse alright so here's
that right
I click him and you have five hundred
forty six thousand people right I see
he's the musician he's a band so let's
say anything Cairo let's just say for
whatever reason I want to be product
placement and I have a new shake or
energy drink or hoodies I would hit this
person up and pick them up and take that
love what you do would love to connect
right or would love to send you my
favorite wines if I was in the wine
business or would love to make three to
four videos or your Instagram account on
me or domesticating it's or and I would
love to give you if you're asking you
don't have the leverage so anytime I'm
hitting somebody up regardless if I'm
bigger or smaller than them I'm asking
so I'm trying to give them luck let's
say you like hip up and let's say and
let's say you love chance the rapper
right so you go to chance the rapper
guys got 2.9 million followers he's
getting hit up a million times a day
when you send him over I think chance I
make videos I'll make you the best
Instagram videos for free for an entire
year
your account will go to seven million
let alone two point nine I will bother
you
I'll just work I'll need access at times
but do you control that let me know look
at my work on my insta not you wash that
over and over and over got to make sure
your Instagram account is on point if
you got that if him or one with boys
actually look at it or somebody was
controlling the account they need to see
those videos and pick their fire that's
the key where you go over and over let
me show you how many should do it you
can literally search the upper east side
you can literally see everybody who's
posting in the area and this person
ain't here so you click this person and
you can literally go up here send them a
message say I like your Instagram
account if you like a plea here come by
what's great about that is these are
individuals who already like to share
their lives so if they come they'll get
a shout-out in the crate so I think you
know you live on board a mouth yeah
what's your business what about this is
what a mouth on steroids he is providing
other people more value I just don't see
people doing it and it is absolutely
going down on Instagram DM the key is do
you know how to Jab Jab Jab right hook
on Instagram Deana for example more
example times I want this to be a header
you should share a giant hash tag there
and literally literally just exported
like anybody who has to be
anything that's here yeah right like
like like if you just be an that person
be like Iraq awesome yeah there'll be
like holy [ __ ] like like it will open up
[ __ ] all of a sudden when you do that
and you also add the Giants punter
whether they know new or not next thing
you know couple months from now they're
doing are going to mean with you yeah
yeah I can see answer vlogs are the
answer DMing meaty rock on Instagram to
get your song on daily B's the answer
every single rapper every single artist
should literally DM every and email a
message every single vlogger that has a
hundred thousand views per video in the
world and give them free music to put in
their vlogs you guys following the work
got it so that's what you do three of
those 39 people say yeah send me a shirt
one of those three that you sent sure to
put it in their store one really smoke
show model walks in there where is it
and away you go
Aisling 24/7 on the Instagram p.m. it is
the 2017 opportunity
[Applause]
you